so you can
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
here we go guys episode
foreign
season three right around the corner
guys
have a dope ass day
real Pull-Ups
yo what's up everybody my name is Thomas
dobiziola whatever you want to call me
this is the dope as usual podcast I am
here with my co-host Marty O'Neill
looking fresh as hell in this white
buffalo for all of you is driving you
guys don't see it and I missed the memo
awareness Monday Night Football tonight
we're wearing our all white so one day
yeah oh we're filming it okay I'm sorry
I'm I'm burnt my bad yeah it's Monday
when you're watching this guys you've
asked so much for this next guest and
I'm just gonna get straight into it this
is the young Mike episode thank you for
showing up bro thank you for coming here
all the way from Texas appreciate you
and you drove yeah we drove from Texas
I did not drive man when you get out in
the middle of nowhere in Texas that [ __ ]
is scary yeah that's no man's land
between the city and the edge of the
state before you hit uh New Mexico right
ain't no gas for like you gotta get gas
or you're gonna be [ __ ] I uh I've
never been to Texas before yeah I'm
going to
Houston and Dallas in January
I feel like Dallas is pretty lit yeah
we're just doing the meet and greets and
stuff you're from San Antonio yeah yeah
I don't know nothing about the others
but except the Spurs bro what's going on
in San Antonio what's the weed situation
like oh the weed because I know Texas
got fired it's pretty lit now because
they used to give us like they used to
arrest us and um all that stuff for weed
but now they just they give you a ticket
or something oh it's decriminalized yeah
but to a certain extent like you can't
have a conversation
that's chill though no out here my home
my cousin my uncle got caught with a 10
pack and they were like yo
might as well be water bro damn yeah
that's why I always tell everybody I got
a lot of homies in Texas going
hopefully not prison this time but it's
like bro you do what I do in a different
state and you're going to prison over it
just [ __ ] move at that point I mean I
know Texas is going to be the best state
in the in the country once weed's legal
it's a big they got everything
you know what I'm saying like as far as
like to grow no I'm talking about for a
[ __ ] population oh yeah you know what
I mean you guys should have the most
sales than anybody in the country man no
yeah yeah it's only a matter of time bro
I don't know what they know the
legalization weed was scary when I was
there I was scared of [ __ ] everything
like okay yeah for a four pack
yeah yeah to go to prison over four
pounds of weed I would be so pissed
every day oh yeah you get caught with
that you you looking at some time for
sure yeah he did like four years oh damn
a pound a year that's whack as hell
anyway real quick before we get on all
the the horrible [ __ ] real quick uh I
want to hop into this I when Marty when
I brought you up to Marty and he brought
me brought you up because we've seen the
comments like yo where's young Mike
episode at we're supposed to do it a
couple of months ago yeah I told Marty
goes what does he do he does music and
also he does weed tube [ __ ]
but I told him if this fool could stay
out of jail I think he's going to be on
the radio and then you hit me up and
then you go yo just popped out of jail
I'm trying to get on the podcast I'm
like all right let me tell Marty uh so I
talked to him I thought it was the
funniest [ __ ] 10 seconds before you told
me that I'm like this Fool's always in
jail but I feel like you know he's gonna
do good with his music [ __ ] I'm like
them I'm brand I'm brand like oh damn
you DM me like oh [ __ ] you last night
episode 100 that's episode 100 you just
getting out perfect here
um so the reason I'm saying that is
because I feel like every time I see you
man you're in trouble in Texas yeah and
it's not like some guns you're allowed
to have guns yeah yeah exactly you just
got moved bro you got to make them I
know it's like it's hard to move from
your place though
yeah I just love my city like you know
it's uh you know I know like you just
hold down your city but yeah I got way
too many like I'm starting this year off
with five charges ugh again like it
don't stop you know it hasn't stopped
since I've since I've met you so to to
bring it back forward
um
I met you we did a video you guys might
have seen it you look completely
different from the video so a lot of
people like that's the same [ __ ]
I did a video with him called make how
to make pipes and bombs at home we just
did it because he was in town like you
know I want to meet this dude as as I'm
sitting there smoking
I go wait he you said something oh
how old are you
there you go
and I looked at my the guy used to work
I went
I didn't know I didn't know if it wasn't
21 because you know back then California
laws well you got to be turning 21 I'm
like
too good of a video I'm not stop ping
but that's when I found out how young
you were bro so this is just starting
for you I feel so with the music when
did you pick that up
like when you were like you know you
freezed only homie smoking a blunt it's
different I'm talking about when you're
like hell I wrote some [ __ ] like when I
first started
um
I was in jail
2017. oh you're a kid still yeah I was I
was in jail 2017 and um
I have barely made YouTube videos
they're popping off but I always loved
music so I would do freestyles before
that whenever you're ready for that one
yeah yeah okay so I was doing I was
doing freestyles right like nothing
serious but one day like I was in jail
just telling everybody I'm gonna be a
rapper I'm gonna be a rapper watch I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do that and I
got out of jail I did my first music
video and then that's when it just
popped off for the city like everyone in
the city heard that song called never
switch you know what I'm saying but yeah
that's the one do you have the uh
you have a memory so it's like that
right whether you have like the gun in
your arm oh that's just hard that's a
good one that's another thing you want
to bring up you you do you make music
videos very well for an independent ass
fool you're hiring people they're
editing the [ __ ] you see you renting
fake this and renting fake trucks and
[ __ ] that's just hard dude like for the
Army thing I was sick we directed every
one of those so like that's just you and
your homies yeah like we we made
everything happen but the video guys did
the thing of course you know yeah of
course of course so 2017 you're what 16.
yeah I was I was like about to be I was
17 I was 17. 17 and get out of jail and
um I started the music but I didn't ever
take Serious until you know when I met
you I didn't still didn't take it
serious until it was like a year later
right yeah I remember I saw it and I I
remember saying like this is the music
you're doing I [ __ ] with this yeah it's
just sick because I the way I was seeing
it was like it was hella energy
and it was a it wasn't like the way you
see a lot of rappers like oh that Trend
they're on that they're on that Trend I
was like I was like this fight so
Mexican comethazine kid [ __ ] hyped
ass music I'm [ __ ] like in my car the
first time I heard I was like get the
[ __ ] out of here this is him I think I
damned your ass was like bro for real
yeah good [ __ ] like I'm hype I'm excited
when people do what they want to do and
like oh it's good I [ __ ] with it I like
it so that's when I first first heard
that you were making music it blew my
mind [ __ ] was dope and that's got a
couple million views on that one I
remember yeah yeah so you're yeah for
being a kid and your city is behind you
I'm you're on top of the world because I
could be wrong the music scene coming
out of San Antonio especially with
hip-hop like really
I've never heard of anybody coming out
of San Antonio I'm sure I'm wrong I'm
sure you know who is there anybody that
we would know of yeah I mean there's
there's a few people that took off from
the city like um we got
on izzy93 you know little man remember
little man your homie yeah yeah we got
little man
um he's chilling we got a little a Chris
tones like be on the lookout for these
names because these people are the next
ones coming up you know what I'm saying
um hoodlum did his thing I don't know if
you ever heard the hoodlum
um
and that's pretty much yeah there's
people that did the thing before but
they're not doing nothing no no more
yeah yeah this is something like like
you're saying like not everybody picks
up a microphone because I'm a rapper now
you were just doing it out of like I was
just [ __ ] with it yeah yeah yeah so
you get that response you know what I
mean you're still in high school you get
that response you're doing your [ __ ]
what's your next step do you do a live I
remember you doing a live show it was a
long time ago right yeah yeah we did
some shows and
um one time we came on the news uh we
just like set the shut the show down
they shut our show down but I told
everybody to go outside and um we just
stood on this green box like you know
those electrical ones yeah yeah did that
had everybody come around us and we just
still rocked out still rocked at the
shop so you're in high school doing this
getting a little buzz what's the next
step for you with music you're starting
to do Studio you're starting to try to
put together projects maybe collabing
with other fools yeah um I've been
working on an album so it's gonna be
like the best stuff that I ever put out
that's why I haven't dropped it yet but
um
I think that's gonna be like crazy it's
gonna go up all independent you're doing
all this by yourself yeah I see that's
the thing like when you're independent
you got to pay for the music videos the
studio time the Beats you gotta pay for
promotion that cause a lot like
sometimes like five bands just for one
song yeah and that's just the stuff
around it to hope it pops yeah
hope you get that money back yeah but
you can't do this expecting to get your
money but I can't do that no because
with anything with Wii shits like yo I
mean we [ __ ] to have fun oh my God I got
paid wow that's how that works same with
music yo I think I can make I can make
it do some [ __ ] so you're out in San
Antonio you're doing your thing your
music's going good you're about what's
two years later is when you started
really going hard that's what I remember
like three years ago right two years ago
yeah like around there
[ __ ] I see you dropping uh like
songs on your YouTube you started using
your YouTube channel as like a yoga
listen to my [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah because
you already got the fan base they're
already there they're already waiting
and if they like it and then you got
lifelong fans yeah it's just a mix it
goes hand in hand like we're talking
about with the we had fulcrum on he's a
YouTuber same thing he's like doing my
weed [ __ ] hit you with some music yeah
the ddg the same same [ __ ] yeah he was a
[ __ ] YouTuber it works so well
because people know you and then oh by
the way now I'm making [ __ ] that you can
listen to and not just smoke weed and
watch and laugh because I remember you
doing wild ass [ __ ] yelling at the
[ __ ] screen in your car talking about
the government and [ __ ]
oh man I can't believe how much time has
gone by
um okay so real quick what's your what's
your playlist looking like
oh like like when you're playing with
the music yeah [ __ ] I've been on like
the wave here and then I I love old
schools especially Texas [ __ ] man like
Texas [ __ ]
yeah yeah for real I only real Texas
fools I really love that I know of is
just zero since I was a kid I [ __ ] with
you yeah I'm so sick I just did a song
with a homie that just did a song with
zero oh nice yeah it's uh Texas [ __ ]
like I'm really tapped in the coach and
you can never leave Texas and still have
a huge [ __ ] following okay you know
what I'm saying like zero like I don't
see him getting that much Fool's got a
cult following still yeah 20 something
years later you know especially with the
internet you got the power of the
internet make a [ __ ] video that
your Wii video gets eight million views
sick the next one's a rap video and like
I can just reiterating what I said but
it's just like hit him with it's like a
combination yeah yeah entertainment by
the way bump this exactly you know yeah
giving them all of you because once you
get that fan base you're like you get to
kind of realize who you are like damn
this is in me I want to put this out
they want to hear it let's do it it was
a great feeling like it came from
people saying I watch videos to I listen
to your music it's like it's crazy like
so I started to getting more of I [ __ ]
with your music I [ __ ] with your music
way more than I watch your video it
started being now I used to watch your
videos but I [ __ ] like I [ __ ] with you I
focus more than you know so I think like
rapping is dope because you know like
YouTube don't really pay good when
you're doing what we what we do I know
yeah exactly you know even if you do
have money as it turns yellow and then
you get like I just got monetized a
month ago a month and a half yeah so do
they not treat music videos the same as
far as like oh yeah age restrictions and
stuff that's the thing see with the
music I kind of like cracked the YouTube
because see I can't have ads on my
videos but when I put my music in a
video it creates ads for my music so
technically I'm getting the money for it
oh yeah yeah yeah nice okay the system
like I don't have to be with the YouTube
Partner program oh [ __ ] I didn't think
about that because I used to use
People's music and all the money they're
getting go to them but if you're [ __ ]
copyrighting yourself
it's dope yo that's a good little
loophole man how did I not think of that
[ __ ]
does YouTube give you a lot of we've had
a lot of we've had like what
seven or eight YouTubers on in a row
almost yeah almost kind of gotten their
takes on their experience with it do you
feel like you've been like fighting
against the grain in terms of
uh uh how YouTube's like treating your
Channel or oh definitely it's like post
the other day yeah man the other day I
had to post a video 11 times I it was
literally perfect like it was up to the
guidelines no smoking no no cursing so I
appealed it they took like three or four
days to get back to me and they said it
was it was good but by then like the
hype of the video is already like you
know slowed down and all that so it's a
process yeah it sucks it's but they're
[ __ ] because like yo we know in the
first 24 hours you're getting the most
views yeah we're not going to give you
no money through this we'll prove you in
three days when you got no more money
coming in yeah they know what they're
doing they know what they're doing yeah
so for for do you get paid off um music
videos like do you get paid off yeah
okay yeah is it the same ratio as as
YouTube videos like you say I don't
smoke weed on my channel I make I make a
million views and I get paid certain
amount you get a million views on your
songs you get same amount that's one
question we've asked like four different
guests I think I think that it is the
same amount like if you get a million
views and you you copyrighted your music
in the YouTube video
I honestly think that would probably get
more money though because they'll
probably throw one in the beginning and
the end wow just because like you know
YouTube plays two ads sometimes it'll
probably do that on a video but a rap
video
like people just want to go straight to
the music I feel like it'll just
probably play one ad and I said no no
add at the end yeah I've seen I've seen
double ads on my YouTube videos before
so I think there's more on that damn
that's like a little loophole man [ __ ]
with that yeah because on the podcast
same feeling like
y'all watch your videos but I [ __ ] with
the podcast every like heavy that is
what we like to see and for you it's the
music damn [ __ ] my music like that
sick it's dope though when you can
provide all sorts of like entertainment
like that yeah they want to listen to
music they want to hear a podcast they
want to smoke weed to hang out with you
exactly yeah so how do you plan on
giving up your time in the New Year in
terms of like the percentage of time
you're going to allocate money and all
that to music videos and production
versus your YouTube and how much you
want to put out of both oh yeah so next
year
it's gonna go crazy I have videos
stocked up music videos ready right now
it's just crazy um
so just be prepared like I'm gonna take
it so serious this year uh coming up and
it's big goals you know does it make
sense to pull off put out like
full-length projects 10 12 songs at this
point or just drip out songs as you make
them I think a project is best
because I've done singles I've hit that
route
um it's not as good when you drop a
project and then you drop the videos
after that project it's like a more of a
hype you're like oh let me see the video
because I love the song girl yeah let me
see this and one thing I always say is a
good song is a good song but if it has
an okay video it's a good song but an
okay song with the dopest [ __ ]
visuals ever can be the biggest video on
YouTube it makes it ten times it makes
it so much [ __ ] better because then
you can associate
what you're hearing with what you saw
it's just come on it's movies it's
movies versus reading or listen to the
radio yeah exactly can you do both
yes that's how it works man I [ __ ] with
that
um so you're dropping hella music videos
that's every time I see you post man
it's like behind the scenes this I'm
doing this knew this knew that [ __ ]
you on top of a car of some kind because
it's sick dude I feel like you found
your direction and that's that's the
direction you need to go because
YouTube's always going to be there but
you know there's only so much time to to
catch attention on what you're feeling
right now to make that song to make that
music you can always yeah how to roll a
joint in five years but maybe the way
you're feeling might not get that song
in five years it's a whole different
thing you know I'm saying like with the
weed videos it's different we come in
here we talk about everything else we've
just so centralized the Wii videos
freeze pipe or you know puffco or
whatever it is topical yeah it's topical
it's it's a niche it's you better be
looking for it with music I mean you
could be from Alaska and find young
Mike's music
you know what I'm saying working on the
[ __ ] oil rig and still listen my list
was from Texas you can still do that
what's up guys taking a moment to talk
about one of our brand new sponsors and
this is hellofresh before we even start
guys Rosie and I are actual customers we
have used hello fresh before save time
money don't waste food and the recipes
are already made for you I know you've
heard the term meal prepping meal
prepping works if you do it hellofresh
eliminates the whole discipline aspect
of that you pick what you want Hello
fresh will deliver it to your door you'd
pick the amount hello fresh is
introducing the festive Fair collection
limit time recipes premium protein
seasonal produce this is the get out of
the holiday slump get back on your
health for everyone out there that is on
the go hellofresh will actually change
your life from personal experience from
me to you it's already prepped
everything's ready to go you don't have
to put the time and energy to go you
know how do you make masala you know
what I'm saying so this is a lot easier
you just heat it up your dinners are
already ready to go it's not processed
TV dinner meals no this is real
ingredients just happens to be packaged
and shipped to your door go to
hellofresh.com forward slash yola21 and
get 21 free meals plus free shipping use
our code yola21 and get started this
year right on the healthy tip again
that's hellofresh.com forward slash
yola21 use our code YOLO 21 that's 21
free meals plus free shipping it's a
win-win situation so once again thank
you so much to hellofresh America's
number one meal kit
what's up guys we are super stoked to
announce one of our brand new sponsors
and like I said before we always try to
team up with sponsors that bring value
to the audience and this right here is
something that we all could use we could
all benefit from this is mint Mobile in
2023 if one of your goals is spend less
save more then why are you still paying
astronomical prices for your phone bill
mint mobile is the first company ever to
sell premium phone service online direct
to Consumer there's no going into the
store waiting in line taking a number
it's online on your time it's as easy as
that guys pick your plan at home and
start saving right now some phone plans
start as low as 15 a month for January
15 take advantage of this if you sign up
for mint mobile and buy a three month
plan you get three months for free
literally 50 off remember this is direct
to customer there's no upsells there's
no little charges this is you see the
price that's the price you get there's
no store visits none of that all the
plans come with unlimited talk and text
high-speed data on the nation's largest
5G Network use your own phone with any
mint Mobile plan and switch over easily
in minutes with esim remember guys take
advantage of the this deal by any mint
mobile three-month plan and get three
months for free all you got to do to get
this deal is go to mitmobile.com forward
slash Yola that's our code if saving
money is something you want to do in
2023 remember to come over to Mint
mobile starting off at just 15 a month
for some plans remember guys hurry up
because this offer ends January 15th
thank you so much to Mint mobile for
sponsoring the show back to the episode
switching over to the weed videos when's
the first one you ever did
first oh man so remember when I told you
I was blowing up in jail for a video it
was a hotter bag of weed itself yeah how
to bag up weed you are a [ __ ] monster
you're at high school doing this [ __ ]
yeah well at that time I was like 16
doing this so I just joined the fans and
[ __ ] yeah like brand new myself as a how
to not get robbed like I just became a
how to like Street like a street Bible
on YouTube oh good [ __ ] but people would
tell me like the game's supposed to be
sold and I told [ __ ] that [ __ ] right you
might say someone's life yeah exactly
how can I get robbed like you gotta
learn to save someone's life you try to
get no hell no you don't want me to tell
me why not to get robbed you're a
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] yeah you
[ __ ] thief
stop [ __ ] my [ __ ] up basically so you
were at the street Bible I like the way
you put that that's cool I was I was
really teaching people like I have real
people that got big money now and
they'll hit me up like bro if it wasn't
ever for you teach me get on my hustle
my grind like they wouldn't be where
they're at so I I look at them like that
I think I want money did somebody put
that in you at a young age in your mind
or was that something yeah see I've been
like hustling or like I was hustling
since 12 you know so I've seen a lot of
things at a young age and then by the
time I was 16 I felt like I was like 30
you know yeah grew up fast you got
brothers and sisters
yeah I got I got brothers older uh two
older one little brother okay okay are
they the ones showing you this like how
to [ __ ] with it are you just learning on
your own like
one brother is church church guy one
brother never he like lived with my
cousins he never seen them my other
buddy's little I was saying it's Pampers
and [ __ ] so
[Music]
um
I just went out in the streets and I
learned this [ __ ] like I hung out with
all the older people I never hung out on
my age you know that's how it happens
bro yeah fighting all once you knock out
some someone older than everybody all
the older is like yeah this was cool I
[ __ ] with him he's a little he's 12.
but he's gotta beat the [ __ ] out of this
kid okay that's like my little brother
Martin saying you're I was telling wrote
my my girl you remind me so much my
little brother martin like you guys look
alike too it's [ __ ] weird bro but as
a kid he's always hanging out with these
older fools knocking out adults and [ __ ]
wild [ __ ] man running around
like that's it's not good but usually it
doesn't grow up fast yeah you grow fast
yeah so I gotta ask
when you came on with that tattoo did
you get punched by your parent or your
mom or grandma see like when I came home
because the Mexican family I felt like
ashamed bro I'm not gonna catch you felt
ashamed you like it though uh
no it was your grandma [ __ ] Smith she
said I look cheap you know what I'm
saying so I felt I felt ashamed like I I
wanted my expectations [ __ ] I thought
that would be a good stand a happy story
I'm so sorry damn it I thought it was
supposed to be all hell yeah my grandma
was pissed damn she said you look cheap
yeah that's [ __ ] sad yeah I'd be so
hurt my grandma told me that I feel you
it's the first time we've heard that on
the show oh man parental reaction well I
just had to ask like a Mexican family
but yeah what happened yeah she wasn't
[ __ ] with that but um my grandma my
sister still hides every tattoo from my
Grandma she's [ __ ] 30s I'm um she
hides everything still wears [ __ ]
full length because it's that Mexican
[ __ ] they're like you're never gonna
hear the [ __ ] end of this [ __ ] dude
ever yeah especially on the face it was
a bad move but
I don't know I just
learning like when I wake up I don't see
it no more you know it just like came
part of me and [ __ ]
I mean I thought
when I first got it it was pretty lit
but then like people started judging me
like the cops once the cops okay okay I
get what you're saying get your hands up
it's like having the uh pistol tatted on
your hand yeah it looks sick it looks
different they're like no for I work at
AutoZone you know what I mean like
you're automatically oh yeah is there a
lot of people walking around with
faceting shutting your area or is it not
so much yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the
thing that they're in gang yeah yeah no
I get what you're saying now that's why
your grandma said that [ __ ] I guess I
get I mean when I saw him like tight I
don't think you look Affiliated you know
it's kind of normal I think it looks
chill I mean now I get it it's like damn
cops look at you twice now uh I get it
yeah especially with the [ __ ] you got
the hair in the jewelry like pull them
over
did your cases like start going up after
the Facebook oh good question oh man
um [ __ ] Marty I want to say yeah I just
want to say is because the phaser but
now that I think about it
start rocking the Nelly Band-Aid maybe
that's why Nelly was rocking the
Band-Aid yeah just uncovered [ __ ]
would you ever get it lasered off that
yeah yeah I looked into it but like I
missed an appointment this is something
you already thought about yeah
I don't think he's gonna I see some
nasty [ __ ] on the internet where they
had to put you put metal under your eye
exactly right here it looked ugly so I
don't know if they have to do that
because it's a little lower you know
what I'm saying you're not I've seen
people with face tattoos completely
removed like gone they just like they
just laser it off yeah yeah it takes a
couple sessions that's what I'm looking
for this couple sessions damn dude I
thought it was gonna be a complete
opposite story but yeah then I [ __ ]
smashed the bottle and I smoked a blunt
but yeah damn yeah I didn't think I was
gonna go the bad bro my bad
um so on to the Wii [ __ ] under the wheat
[ __ ] you're 16. you're making your Wii
video 17 making your Wii videos does
your family know about this
nah see like I didn't live with my
family when I started that what are you
doing I was like I was living with
someone else in like a house like a big
ass house oh you were do damn you real
fast man that sucks I feel you cause
that's what was me too like 18 like um
out of here if I could go earlier I
[ __ ] would yeah yeah so I'm doing
this and they don't know none of this
I'm still gonna scrap it up right now no
you still going to school back then yeah
I was going to school damn you still
went to school good [ __ ] yeah all right
you kept up with it no I didn't keep up
with it oh but you showed up yeah okay
okay try to sell just someone weed I'm
assuming that's why I went to school no
I low-key I I just went because I was on
probation no actually
it's a long story but
probation made me go to school and then
they they told me about this package
that you could get and apparently you
don't have to go to school you just have
to do the packing so I I got I bought
the packages to make the probation shut
up and I just stayed in the streets I
didn't go to school I didn't even do the
packet I think I lost it oh but isn't
that crazy hey you got in so much
trouble here's a get out of school free
car they do that's a lot of my home is
like finish the packet for each year and
each quarter right the essay you're done
you're gonna go to school it boils down
to like school doesn't actually matter
just just
get out of here yeah dude I don't know
how they do that like I'm over here
trying I was a 4.0 student from like
six to eighth grade because my mom's
I'll give you money if you get A's and I
was like you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up
cause I'm smart I just don't give a [ __ ]
and then once I started selling weed no
no parent ever just paid their kid off I
told you this I'm saying except you oh
okay yeah I got math student of the year
in eighth grade and then they were like
and then I started using it for Math and
weed I'm like yo it's the same [ __ ] I'm
over it I I stopped doing I basically
stopped going to school but I was there
yeah like I was just checked out half
asleep or just waiting to think about
who am I gonna sell we to at lunch time
now you're telling the Maybach dealer
like can I get it for like two pounds
yeah there's a lot like that's three
pounds over the price like it's a car
sir like it's still three pounds on my
price it was 2018.
come so sorry off topic my bad you're 16
you're still going to school because
probation is making you you're making we
videos when you go to school or Fool's
like yo are you the [ __ ] I just
watched on YouTube no you see I was
living with this girl right and her dad
like her parents
so um
her parents tell me her dad comes up to
me one day and she's like and he's like
he says of something I said in a video
it was like
so you you she said something you're
gonna teach me how to sell weed or no it
was like how to make money video he's
like so you get to teach me how to make
money and I was like what the [ __ ] like
it was literally get recommended to his
YouTube like somehow he found it on
YouTube I was like pop you know because
those videos no one was doing those and
uh I was like what the [ __ ] and so he
started watching my I'm doing them in
his house
I'll be back in the wheels
[Laughter]
big old dude I was like I have respect
for him so I'm like [ __ ] I can't do this
in this house no more he knows like so I
started like I started doing them
outside if you watch these videos old
videos like I all started my my channel
I have now
um you'll see me outside or in my car
that's where the car is yeah and real
quick I just realized how much you were
slouching holy [ __ ] this for this
[ __ ] game six inches or six feet of
height right now
I looked down I look up oh you're tall
as [ __ ] I forgot uh my bad so this man
tells you he knows what you're doing you
start doing them outside in your car and
that's why it all started was he pissed
though yeah good question oh yeah I see
like oh he was mad man he I this guy
punched my car one time like
cause he don't like me doing like one
time I was doing a video and like he
just comes out of his car
and like you just try to punch my window
out
and I drove off though and I was like
what the [ __ ] like this dude is really
like angry I I feel enough because I'm
right outside his crib doing this
innocent attacks us back then too like
yeah I get it but he couldn't be like yo
can you not do videos here he didn't say
nothing no he never really said that
like he's just kept it inside yeah he
kept [ __ ] and like um was it
your girlfriend's parents is it your
sandwich
oh how long had you been there like like
a year oh but you're letting the kid
live with you yeah I know that's why
he's like
all right I understand why he got upset
yeah I get it I get it but did not say
anything and just resort to I'm gonna
bust this window out I hope I'm in the
video
I'm gonna make I'm gonna go viral
yeah that man he's cool though you know
like after after time he like started
like he told me like he reminds me of
him because Loki like he used to be
doing that uh but like not on camera
yeah yeah
so
and it's his daughter he's I I
understand I get it so all your videos
are outside you're doing your thing when
do you when do your family find out what
you're doing
damn this is always the story so it's
always a good one Whatever YouTuber is
it's not often that you get to get this
story from people there's not very many
wee people yeah on Earth and this is his
first [ __ ] interview time doing
this [ __ ]
that's why we have the headphones yeah
uh uh so
like the music bro the music like my mom
somehow found out about the music I
didn't tell him you know
but
um
she found out about the music and she
found out first my grandma doesn't know
so I thought you know so my mom finds
out she she doesn't really care you know
my mom's from the streets she's like
she's Thug you know what I'm saying
she's thugging basically so she just
tells me like
I don't know she she didn't really see
it as like a real job she didn't think
that the music would give me more than a
regular job she she felt like scared I
guess
and uh she telling me like you think
you're gonna get more money than your
brother like you think you get more
money than like a real job you know what
I'm saying yeah music from the YouTube
videos and I was like
I was like yeah I'm gonna go on one like
I know you know what I'm saying like I
know I know I could like I just I just
knew it I believe in this one in a
million sure trust me yeah yeah because
I had a real job I worked for like one
week and that [ __ ] [ __ ] where it was
not for me DQ Dairy Queen yeah you can't
see you putting on a uniform I can't see
it bro yeah they clean and I was I was
building Like Houses like I was [ __ ]
doing construction and all that [ __ ]
like
but the money wasn't good like I got
that I worked one week I got 100 in like
17 at the taxes damn yeah I was like
[ __ ] that like they treat me like a
slave we clock out and we're still
working like cleaning and scrubbing the
photos and [ __ ] so I got this YouTube
check my first Revenue one it's 300. I
said [ __ ] DQ [ __ ] this construction
because I was getting like it was a
two-man job and I was getting [ __ ] on
it I was getting all the I was doing all
the labor work this guy was just putting
the puzzle pieces together ah you're the
runner
okay
uh yeah so I just quit and I started
YouTube and I believed and I could make
mode and now I I really make more like
my payoneer checks every week it it's
amazing like I just chill
and just keep getting money you know
like a regular job
but if you work hard you know that's
when you see the bigger money like the
millions that's what I'm trying to do
this year that's the next level first
level is like sustain be able to push
forward more than a regular job and then
it's that next level of like all right
now I'm [ __ ] balling through this
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah success that's when
you're when you uh wake up to money like
oh [ __ ] yeah while I was asleep that's
the ultimate feeling that I think
everybody chases man yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah so with the weed [ __ ] obviously
that's not they don't [ __ ] with us
they're not going to pay us right now
and if they do oh bro we can both buy a
building soon like we're gonna it's
gonna be great if YouTube decides to pay
us that'd be sick
also we're not going to depend on it so
you win another route you're doing your
thing so but with the weed videos you
you're making the street Bible I know we
keep ranting and [ __ ] but you make all
that your parents find out or your mom
found out about the weed yeah so we were
on that topic and then Grandma found out
but Grandma she's cool right like
um you know Grandma at least one week in
the 80s or 70s whatever you grab a dip
yeah oh [ __ ] all my grandma's she's
usually latex lady bro yeah
so she like she she wasn't really
tripping but like
she she just randomly hit me up like
oh yeah I seen that video I'm like what
like I was watching the video you know
and she's talking about she's seen that
one and I was like no way and she's like
yeah I watch your videos and I was like
what the [ __ ]
I didn't even know bro like oh we were
probably mentioning my grandma in some
videos and [ __ ] like she watching them
hoes and [ __ ]
what was her vibe like I I used to make
music and [ __ ] I went through this like
God damn I know my parents are having to
hear those wow look at they didn't see
the first channel I had in that how to
bag of weed like that oh you had two
channels yeah that one got deleted oh
what'd you get up to before they deleted
your [ __ ] this is like 25k but I ran a
million reviews on that but wait they
deleted the channel yanked the whole
thing yeah when I woke up and that girl
I was doing she just like
this channel does not exist oh yeah
that's the one or you keep doing this
oh it was [ __ ] I had no strikes I know
nothing too I heard it I mean I remember
that happened yeah and now that was Foul
Play right there because you're about to
hit a mill that was it's right before
the night before yeah right
99.999
it was some [ __ ] honestly you got it
back he got it back
it's just like [ __ ] so your grandma
watches it you're doing your [ __ ]
um when you're out and about do you I
mean obviously bro you're at the time
you're 20 years old you're already doing
music your music's already getting big
I I would I would imagine I would if
like
try to put a stamp on it
if I was 20 years old my music's Papa
and my reach is popping hood star comes
to mind a little bit like yeah I'm gonna
walk outside smoke a joint like yeah
thanks because that's that's why I
imagine like all the movies I ever seen
like because when I I don't I don't [ __ ]
with I don't go out I don't want my
version know where I'm at you don't know
where I'm at [ __ ] no I'm the opposite of
like Heisenberg yeah like I don't like
being out I don't like [ __ ]
know where I'm at because I don't just
yeah of course it's different with you
like yo it's Gotta gone leave them alone
like over there like he's smiling yeah
[ __ ] thumbs up every time I see him
you know so it's still different but for
you you're 20 years old this shit's
popping I mean I'm saying it like it's
20 years ago and [ __ ] this is recent bro
but I'm just trying to go
chronologically so you're 20 you're
doing your thing uh or 19 20 you're
doing your thing that's when I meet you
you're still doing your weed [ __ ] then
you decide to go hard as [ __ ] the
music and now I feel like you're going
music heavy 80 over
twenty percent wheat [ __ ] 80 music like
everything you post is what I imagine
an artist on a label would post like
high quality this not posting questions
and how it looks yeah you can see it
like it's weird we've had so many
artists come through we've had so many
artists pitched at us and everything and
it's like it's something that you just
know and you see it's that level of like
commercial production where it's like
that next level of quality and just
like this person's career is leveling up
so you could see that you're like oh
this woman what are you going oh yeah
doing this also you smoke a lot of
blunts huh nah I'm done no say but the
way you squeeze that joint
because it's squeezed like this that's
only blood smokers do that [ __ ] I saw it
like that's where the Cherry fell out I
gotcha because I looked I saw the Cherry
but I go what did I do no no that's
something okay he's oh my brother some
other [ __ ] blood smoker squeezed the
[ __ ] out of my joints it's like they
bend that [ __ ] in half I don't know why
it always [ __ ] happens
um back over here okay so you're uh I
know I should have rolled more weed I
told Marty before we started like I
smoked four or five of these every
episode
and the past couple episodes I noticed
me going uh
uh wait what I [ __ ] hate that I do
that so I'm trying to dial it back just
slightly just a little bit just a little
bit yeah just a little professional
trying my best because I've been getting
[ __ ] High yeah
um no that [ __ ] got me lit I'm not gonna
it's good weed and it's not like I'm
couch lock I'm just oh my it's one thing
to smoke four giant joints and it's
another thing to do it and then
interview somebody in a coherent man
that's what I'm saying like I can
interview fools it's just a four of
these I'll [ __ ] lose contract a
contract see [ __ ]
Jesus Christ
I'll lose where I'm at I'll lose my
place yeah that's some successful Stoner
[ __ ] you just damn it my bad all right
so you're doing the weed thing man oh
you're doing your [ __ ] I just want to
keep it I actually put my nose in order
I'm like you know what categorized let
me stay professional we're doing our
damn Ted talk [ __ ] next week I'm trying
to like
hello I just got slightly terrified it's
less than a week away you got slightly
terrified when I looked at the cat I
mean like I'm like damn oh it's less
than five oh yeah it's coming it's
different when it's like the week up
yeah yeah no I feel you
um so that's why I'm trying to smoke
[ __ ] 12 grams on the show right now
so back to what I was saying as I keep
repeating the [ __ ] out of myself
um weed [ __ ] summed up boom you're still
doing your videos but it's just I feel
like it's getting a lot harder and are
your videos getting just [ __ ] on right
when you upload them like age restricted
immediately you know sometimes it will
um
I had to take a break just because like
it's draining like my
like mentally draining you know what I'm
saying like you work so hard on a dope
ass I edit my videos I you know how it
is bro yeah I love when I could relate
to someone you know what's up brother
like do your own [ __ ] I was editing hard
ass edits and then for what just to like
get Shadow banned like from an age
restriction you know instantly too it's
sick it's [ __ ] terrible how much a
week it's [ __ ] three days worth of
work altogether
and it's like dude nobody saw it [ __ ]
and then three months later you see
comments I didn't even see this
[ __ ] put a lot of work into that
[ __ ] pulled it all nighter
editing actually [ __ ] exactly I hate
that man it's it's discouraging as [ __ ]
honestly I get what you mean and every
video at a time every single video I had
to take a break now this past year the
worst huh yeah 2022 I don't know talking
about that child babies like is it meant
for child oh is this meant for kids they
click notes like automatically
restricted that's what [ __ ] everything
well also UFC's not meant for kids but
you still have [ __ ] unread restricted
videos on YouTube videos dude the amount
of [ __ ] that all right let's get into
this yeah but there's a girl on YouTube
I don't know if you guys seen it she's
pretty she does the get ready with me
makeup [ __ ] and hits the Pookie pipe
while she [ __ ] does it right what
roasting it roasting it torchlighter
and then she's putting on her makeup and
like yeah [ __ ] like uh and she starts
talking like she's whacked out of her
mind hella pretty young as [ __ ] what is
she doing in her [ __ ] parents house
smoking a pookie butt
deleted channels still up how the [ __ ]
on Earth can you smoke Chris on [ __ ]
camera you should do a whole series of
reacting to videos that aren't age
restricted we'll just look at the camera
off YouTube
yeah I can't believe it's I I can't
believe it's still up yeah there we go
but nah dude there's a kid uh there's a
kid that looks like me uh like a young
me but he [ __ ] smokes crack on
YouTube he's got like 13 million views
it's been 2006 still on YouTube he's
sitting there smoking crack after school
kid yeah bro there's some of the [ __ ]
that I see bugs me I really should have
rolled more weed I might just roll weed
right here while we're going oh God okay
you're going to a [ __ ] I'm gonna just
go like this I'm gonna go like this all
right so we don't so we block it from
YouTube
[Music]
oh cool what's that oh yeah yeah
um in that backpack right there you're
gonna see a black jar it's OG you roll
up whatever you want of that and in
there there should be a grinder it's a
pink grinder yeah
thank you
um okay yeah please no it's a black jar
like a long black jar and there should
be a pink grinder in there
yeah and there's hella papers and [ __ ]
over there too but yeah smoking Chris
getting ready yeah that one crazy [ __ ]
yeah that's [ __ ] blew my mind
um
all right cool chapters Marty chapters
ready
I'm gonna get into a segment and then I
I got some questions
so it's harder because you're 23 it was
only seven years ago I had a question I
asked the internet one time and then
Mario like we should ask that on the
show
so you currently right now this is a
question you have to think like
yes or no
16 year old you walks in and trying to
fight are you gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
him or is he [ __ ] you up
[Applause]
[Music]
I see that's always a good one man it's
a it's a good question because you have
to think like
that was crazy or some people go I was a
nerd yeah I'd beat the [ __ ] out of me
you know what I mean there's always that
and then you always have to reflect like
damn 16 year old knee 60 on me was
trapping it out Little Wayne so he
probably beat the [ __ ] out of me I gotta
be honest but
we're good I remember that I've gone
over that many times so okay I have a
little segment because you do lots of
story times you do a lot of story times
uh as one of the other weed people that
do stories like they're fun so I have a
couple all right I have a couple I want
to ask you about and I can't remember
I can't remember if it was one time or
multiple
border patrol oh man okay yeah it was it
was multiple then I just remember I
think it was like you screaming at your
video or your camera
and then yelling at the border patrol
guy next to you while you're in your car
yeah that was the video
what is happening you live how far is it
San Antonio from the border no you see
I'm coming from Cali
that's not that border patrol I'm coming
like when we go back that's like Arizona
state line [ __ ] we're going like it's in
Texas though
so luckily they shut down everyone in
Arizona but like this one on the way in
Arizona and then there's one on the way
back there's a checkpoint to leave Texas
like it's coming it's like once you it's
before El Paso there's a challenge oh
it's New Mexico and and
right there like well that's from
Arizona like once you I don't even know
like but once you once you're about to
get to El Paso it's that checkpoint
right there and they're dick heads what
are they looking for what the [ __ ] do
they want I mean you're in America still
yeah like it's it's sick because
I remember this hat this isn't like five
times the border patrol so the first
times like I used to always just bring
whatever you know I didn't give a [ __ ] I
didn't think it was a thing like I
didn't so I would go with my homie and
we'll just come back with whatever the
[ __ ] we want and they always just said
like this like they never gave me a
problem
I get this SUV
now I don't think nothing of it I'm
thinking
it's I don't know what I'm saying so I
Got This SUV now I'm driving back
as I get [ __ ] with I guess it's
because it's an SUV now they say roll
down your window it never told me that
before
then they say pull over the second day
this is where it all started like the
first time stomach drop and I don't have
nothing on me but like personal use
probably like an ounce you know but I
have my firearm I always keep it fine
you know because you could we're in
Texas so
I have my firearm and that ounce so you
can't have it both of those really yeah
so they put me in a Paddy Wagon they're
searching my car for like five hours I'm
in a Paddy Wagon like [ __ ] like just
waiting and waiting and waiting because
there's no real officers that could do
something there they can't really do
nothing there so they caught a sheriff
there's only one Sheriff like in the
next
100 mile radius type of [ __ ] like it's
small town right there so come here's
the sheriff I'm waiting like two hours
for the sheriff on top of all the hours
I'm already
so
Sheriff gives me a ticket
and they let me go
that was cool you know what I'm saying
I come go to caddy again I come back and
again they [ __ ] with me again pulled
over the second air it smells like weed
well I don't have nothing to happen for
five hours again they put me on my way
and one time I thought
going to La I thought I'd gone to San
Diego will be uh faster to get to Cali
after
hell no three [ __ ] checkpoints San
Diego's [ __ ] for weed it's California
but they look at you like oh hash yeah
I'm gonna shoot your ass but they don't
give a [ __ ] bro they're like yo that's
method I don't know what it is I might
be wrong but like a couple years ago my
homie just had Edibles and went to jail
putting a lot but still what the [ __ ] so
you wouldn't be San Diego hit three
checkpoints and you guys I just didn't
know that there's checkpoints leaving
your state why why I don't understand
see there's one like in Arizona and they
should there I don't know why there was
one even right there so they took that
one down now they don't want to come in
oh got you but the other one is on the
way back and that one's always open and
they [ __ ] I'm not gonna lie like I'm
not I'm not trying to talk down on
Border Patrol but
but the San Diego one economy there
they stole money for me too they took
your money they took some money man like
they gave me my money back but it was
300 short
rip my seats up just stack them yeah
they just peeled it real quick so I knew
how much I had it was an equal amount
300 less somehow I want to get my money
back why they even have your money I got
to be on like what's up they pulled me
out and they searched me down they put
me in a Paddy Wagon they're doing
whatever they want at the patrol at the
Port they're violating me all sorts of
ways it shouldn't even be like that it's
not like the weeds of thing here it's
not thinking about you smell like we
like it's California yeah they they just
like your name must be on the list bro
like I think once it happened one time
that red flag yeah so like yo this guy
he's gonna talk [ __ ] back so you know
get his ass there must be like a little
flag on your name they know the license
plate yeah of course if they're Paddy
wagging you every time bro
so I stopped coming
and I just stayed away from that [ __ ]
now you know right clean you got it
right how you supposed to no [ __ ]
leave in the car you don't say damn you
can't have all right so you you can't
have weed in the car if you have your
gun in Texas yeah it can be a combo but
what if it's in the weeds in the trunk
or something no I see it like let's say
your homie has weed and you got your gun
that's that's acceptable because it's
not in your position oh okay so but yo
let's go get some weed I'm gonna take my
gun hold my weed oh my little uh oh
seven real quick that's cool even when
you go like a few zips on game should we
get a ticket but like I wouldn't even
let my homie hold it that much but in
general you know that's just how you can
walk around with rifles on your back but
you can't have this exactly I love taxes
I love Texas man I just got arrested in
L.A yesterday so that's what I was gonna
move on to oh yeah no no no no perfect
because when I when I brought you up I
said hey
could you hit me up at two in the
morning I'm like I'll hit me two in the
morning I'm like all right cool cool
I'll hit you back I'm like 12 12 o'clock
comes just got out of jail it'd be a
good story oh [ __ ] I told him already
like yo he just got out of jail again
that's what I said this was going to be
on the radio you just gotta stay out of
jail so you can do more videos and [ __ ]
so what happened bro you were here for
what a day
yeah one day bro you're here for a date
and you went to jail overnight
yeah I went to the the day like the one
the first day okay man type [ __ ]
what's going on
apparently I was in South Central L.A
you know it is yeah so like you you
heard about PMB right
the rapper yeah yeah of course yeah it
should set us out we were right there
you got arrested there yeah we were
right there like two streets down so I
didn't know
we're all like lit we just came from a
cliff you know popped some fireworks you
know just uh
um
we were just trying to go to the casino
and then
I don't know this cop just I'm driving
right in this colleges like he's in he's
in like you know like the light it's a
red light and all the cars right here
we're going straight
he had no he wasn't even turning right
so we're going straight and then I see
him turn right I'm like oh wait in this
car yeah yeah
so I'm like oh it's not like you're
riding in a [ __ ] hoopty with stickers
and lights on it bro what the hell I'm
driving the speed limit I'm doing my
thing you know what I'm saying I'm
hitting the blinkers right so
I seem to get behind me I'm like oh [ __ ]
maybe he's just chilling right and then
I I get into my right lane and I'm
driving
then I don't know he just gets behind me
again
I'm like look
so I I I'm not gonna say too much but
yeah I'm like damn
I don't even know what's going on like
am I consent in Texas where a lot of
have concealed carry
apparently he is a little different yeah
it's different you have to have it in
the back seat like in the backpack trunk
or locked exactly and it has to be
locked why the [ __ ] you who's supposed
to do something so you can get shot when
you're going back to your trunk going
hey it's legal hold on Sir Don't Shoot
Me Up yeah time out [ __ ] wait
wait mine's in the back I got it no I
can't do that what I would have never
even came here you know what I'm saying
like real life spill because
so
I'm sorry sir I'm thinking I was moving
clean I'm am I concerned I'm moving how
we could in Texas I feel I I even have a
legal carry because like I know you
could only have up to 10 Rounds here so
I had to leave okay
and um
they hit me with a felony like they're
trying to but you know let's not yeah
here we go so yeah they just um
apparently I couldn't carry it right
there I had to have it in the back so it
was um something that I started but I'm
going to this La jail
feeling like like a movie or something
bro like
um
it was cool though it wasn't that bad it
wasn't
um downtown L.A yeah I know exactly
where they took you yeah yeah so uh it
was cool you know because where I'm from
our jail is is sick Bro like bad in
County really in the country like
otherwise San Antonio jail look it up
like we came out awesome for what like
what's so bad about it it's like how
they treat you like you go in there and
you're sitting on a cold ass chair
moving around you can't sleep
for like
24 hours
and that's just to get bailed out and
then if you don't get bowed out or if
you're still waiting they'll put you in
the back which is even harder to get out
because then from the back you have to
go back to that waiting spot and then
you get out
so it's sale after sale it's sick like
it's no blanket no you're cold as [ __ ]
bro like it's [ __ ] hell they give you
Johnny sacks and [ __ ] they don't give
you what they gave me in that leg what
does that mean it's like a [ __ ] cold
ass sandwich but like it's like me it's
not even but only it's nice oh yeah it's
mystery me bro cancerous
that's nasty as hell I don't eat that
[ __ ] you either you get sick
automatically like yeah my homies like I
ate bread for like three and a half
months I ate corn
damn yeah cause I'm eating the meat [ __ ]
was blue on the edges I was green as
[ __ ] God it's me yeah no it's like
it's some mystery meat [ __ ]
I like that so San Antonio was really
like that I didn't know that but here I
got a blanket I got a phone in my cell
like they I could call whoever what the
hell there's a high truck I got
electricity right just leave like I I
slept bro I slept good I had the blanket
and the bunk bed like I wasn't that bad
question no it's not gonna stick like
hey man I was I was fine I'm not
shooting out the window what the [ __ ] so
you got profiled got pulled over because
that car tells me I have insurance
check my license plate it doesn't say
pull his ass over and we'll ask
questions later everything's legit yeah
you know what
you couldn't have saw that either if
he's on the right side ah I see I don't
it's not like he saw like your face when
uh he's got something on him he probably
saw the Texas plate and he was like oh
that's probably what it is reason that
they have for pointing over off time
nothing fam yeah you got nothing I did
everything in my blinker like my I have
a good lawyer I'm gonna have some pretty
footage you know because there is no
reason to pull me over
damn so she happened just like that with
my homie literally in front of my
warehouse a couple weeks ago so as he
was pulling up to my spot same exactly
literally to the T what you just said
it was some [ __ ] it was he you know
what's crazy about California though as
this fills the rest to my homie and
taking him in he's like yo can he my
friend got my get my bags and [ __ ] he's
like you've been chill bro you can take
it and he saw I have the warehouse with
all of our cars out here it's not like
we're like
like Robin fools like uh as our business
and our friend was just pulling up he
just got he's on felony probation so
it's all bad
but the cop's like yeah you can give him
this and the white cop the dude did not
want to give me the bag he looked at me
like I was a piece of [ __ ] get back up
Sir back up it's like bro this is my
property and you're telling me back up
with your hand like this
anyway the Mexican cops like give him
his back obviously he was in charge like
give him the bag
and the white dude remember I told you
walked up was like here what is this he
goes it's a bag full of weed
and I looked in it was like a QP hella
strains because I put it inside and I
walked away it's like California huh and
I put it inside like damn that's crazy
as hell like no you can keep all of it
we just want the guns
oh [ __ ] damn I killed him oh he was he
looked like he was gonna choke my ass
out dude he [ __ ] despised me buff ass
[ __ ] cop with a flat top like brand
new he was looking at me like why do you
got this car huh you know once I get
[ __ ] paid a year like he looked at me
like who the [ __ ] are you I'm like oh my
God I had a joint it's my [ __ ]
property like it's my [ __ ] I'm gonna do
whatever I want smoke porn out of the
warehouse
yeah but do the same [ __ ] dude I don't
know what it is about California he just
got yanked just like you the same thing
like what'd you get put over for like
I wanted to see what you had basically
is what they should say like I think
you'd have something yo he wanted to see
if I had weave see like California I
didn't I didn't I remember everything he
said he said
you don't have nothing major in the car
right like both like he because of my
I'm pushing my taxes plate
I'm pretty sure you probably thought I
was driving oh I'm going home yeah
and we chilling trying to revive like
they just ruining it's not even that
dude prop D prop 64. smells not a
probable cause in California I don't
know if you know that not yet can't even
it smells like it smells like weed like
so luckily not a probable cause you
can't even look in here yeah so don't
ever have a cop unless they can see
physically see smoke in your car
so even if you're getting pulled over
while smoking roll the windows down
and unless he walks up and sees smoke
moving in your car
with his body cam it's he legally can't
say do you got weight yeah prop 64 man
love it these guys just [ __ ] had weed
all in the back yeah but you're in
California you might bought it legally
too at a store uh you know what I mean
like you got a receipt if you have to
pay taxes for it three sets of taxes
yeah three three sets 100 isn't that
crazy dollars the other day in Texas
I was pissed I'm like no damn you really
came out here just to hang out huh I'm
popping fireworks I went by legally
I'm just experiencing California I see I
had a zoo We got the zoo yeah we gotta
uh I mean we have a bunch of them
somewhere there's fireworks your thing
because I heard in one of your videos it
kicked me out of school for the
fireworks he was telling me about a
prank and uh oh yeah she's like she just
pranks on his friends go asking me about
the firecracker blunt that was my
favorite one that's [ __ ] up by the way
that was my favorite one yeah that was
scar me bro I couldn't put like a like a
black jacket no that would that would
blow your nose off
into the eyes I'm gonna have to fight if
someone did that yeah the little red one
right is that what you use the little
thin red ones nah I use the those little
poppers
oh is that what you did yo those new
ones are deadly remember the circle ones
that just Twisted paper no have you seen
the new ones they look like firecrackers
they look like firecrackers but they pop
you've seen them yeah they hurt they
[ __ ] hurt don't throw them at people
I found out they [ __ ] hurt they
popped on me oh [ __ ] bro you might as
well just
smack my [ __ ] turn off the little
[ __ ] they look like yeah yes but no
now they're little firecrackers when you
throw them they got a little gunpowder
and they hurt oh [ __ ] yeah they look
like drugs the ones from back in the day
they look like drums it was like sexy
Coke right yeah but it does look like
little [ __ ] 10 sex you could put them
never mind
about to give it away and [ __ ]
um Okay so
I had the story time and you went right
into it for La so the other story time
was the first time you're getting in
trouble out there what's the first time
you're actually getting in trouble with
that smile
memories uh
short hair me right little little Mike
at the time that's what I used to be
[ __ ] little Mike I was 12 years old bro
I got my first felony damn at 12. well
for what see like there's this place
called the Good Samaritan and it was
like a daycare place but apparently I
guess a daycare somewhere they teach so
they counted it as a school tagging on
the school is a felony so I got the
spray cans with my homie and uh his name
was Linden or some [ __ ] like that and uh
it was actually neon like this like like
that like uh it was an orange neon like
that but sure yeah so we were spray
painting we're getting it done you know
okay sir thank you sir thank you thank
you yeah yeah thank you so much
so we got we got
um some cans we used to steal the cans
from this like apartment complex we used
to jump the fence and stealing from
their their truck that's how it was
smart yeah smart well how do you get
spray cans yeah they said I get an older
full to buy them for us hey defensive
high as [ __ ] too we would need to work
for it
Bob and leave but um so we had this
orange neon spray can and it was a wack
ass one so where it got all on our
fingers
so we're going to the park we walked to
the park and I'm watching this [ __ ] off
you know what I'm saying I washed my
hands off I tell Lenny I said bro wash
your hands like he he's black so the
neon like she really stood out you know
I'm like bro watch your hands man he's
like no I'm good so we're walking back
and we see this cop going this way he's
looking at us but I'm not I'm not really
looking like I looked real quick I know
not took that yeah Linden's like I I
ain't this dude like broke his neck and
[ __ ] yeah and he's like bro he was
looking at me we gotta go it's like we
like run to this like to the end of the
apartments the cop comes like this I
have like a bong full of like three
pipes I have like this bubbler this
Steamroller and like a little grinder
and all this [ __ ] like Texas back then
we oh man they hated it like shut the
[ __ ] up my head like [ __ ] like that damn
catching me so I had a backpack I throw
the backpack real quick he even sees me
but he was distracted because he was
very racist he went straight for Linden
straight for the black dude and I'm the
one with the with the spray can in my my
pants and I'm the one with the with the
backpack for the bones so why he was
distracted by linden like all [ __ ]
races I pulled off my backpack I dropped
on the floor and I just had the spray
camera here so he searches me and then
he finds a spray can and he's like uh
like this he knows from there it's me
boom he gets a spray can and then he
sees the backpack and he opens it and he
finds it
I didn't let my bro go down for that
question so I I say it was mine you know
what I'm saying um they charge me for
drug paraphernalia like marijuana you
know what I'm saying and then they they
typing for that felony uh so they just
went around and said that's orange they
did it
oh because how they connect how they
connected because linen was looking like
he said oh you know we actually said how
did you know he said your bro your buddy
was looking at it at me
and I was like damn fool and he didn't
watch that everything was just bad at
that moment but hey your kids too though
12 years old young Mike they they take
me to this like one spot to where they
let my grandma tell me a few words like
they let Lyndon get a few words from his
fam like it was weird they never would
do that like to a regular arrest you
know and my grandma comes and she is mad
as [ __ ] like she's telling me off making
me feel so bad and
um I've never been to jail this is my
first time so yeah you're a little kid
yeah I'm like what the [ __ ] so they're
they're like you can just [ __ ] sleep
with roaches and there's [ __ ] rats on
the floor that's what they were telling
you yeah and bro bro starts crying
so we go and um
it was an experience that like back then
juvenile was really bad like it was
really thugging they had [ __ ] separated
from gangs like damn yeah oh yeah Y8 is
way worse man I've heard that story 50
times so we we they put me in a blood
mod so I'm over here like 12 years old
with big old black dude it's [ __ ]
balling up getting bought on and [ __ ]
you know tell me how young Mike in jail
juvenile sucks because you're gonna get
better you know what I'm saying you
don't get Bail no you gotta wait two
weeks so I'm waiting two weeks then I'm
out you gotta get on probation there's
no way around that oh [ __ ] you know that
so now I'm on probation and and luckily
I completed it so they dropped my felony
at a young age to give a kid a felony
for art artwork is crazy and guess what
guess what technicality I drove by that
building
the Wild's not even there no more just
to throw a kid in jail for a while just
to [ __ ] take that wall off I was
pissed I'm like that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
right there damn that's so [ __ ] up
right there I don't know how you could
be like how old was the your friend same
age it was like 13. so damn this Fool's
really wasting his time and attacking
two little boys
wow but you know one thing I kind of
feel bad for cops like that because
what do they do when they go home like
when they're falling asleep like yeah I
got that little kid like you know that's
why they're like
do they feel stupid when they sleep do
do they have a con you know what I mean
like I'm going to sleep sometimes I'm
like damn I think I took that last piece
of pizza when I was 12. yeah I [ __ ]
feel bad so how do you you know how what
do you feel like going to sleep and
that's what makes me feel bad for me
like I don't have to do that every night
they don't feel bad when they go to
sleep though I guess
yeah they're not thinking twice about
that shirt but I don't know that's just
you'd like to think that they are but
they're not that's crazy I don't really
[ __ ] I don't even [ __ ] sleep but
back then you get caught with a nickname
I got caught with a nick sack one time a
[ __ ] a Reggie five dollars yeah I'm
trash
and guess what shut the [ __ ] up
getting punched in my my arm you know
like aggressive for we like and now look
at like how'd you get calm with it
that's a funny story see I had this
jacket it was like furry and I had a
pocket like in the line not like you go
like that and it's that pocket oh yeah
if I had it zipped up so
we went through this wild Chase like we
we used to do parkour back then
you had to earn that [ __ ] Nickelback
we used to do parkour back then yeah
like we would count on roof since it's
just around this school roof
and we just like you know like sometimes
the things are open on the top so we
open the thing well one of my homies did
and we went in we didn't really do a
classroom it was like the Portables huh
like I don't know where it was but like
we just wanted to see it was in there
like and so we're searching it there's
nothing but like Capri Suns and a bag of
marshmallows sick we take those we're
like [ __ ] it we're high as [ __ ] but then
we go up and like apparently there's a
cop I see my homies jump off this high
ass [ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm like hell no
I'm not [ __ ] dumb they're kind of
older so they're kind of a little taller
I'm not jumping off this high-ass [ __ ] I
I remember I slid down no I didn't even
slid down the pole uh I had to go back
inside the building and go out through
the doors so I go boom
running
I don't see nothing I still have my
marshmallows and [ __ ] I jumped the fence
and um I jumped the fence like crazy
like it was those Pokey ass fences and I
didn't give a [ __ ] like I just said
shoot jump that hoe and ran
my dumbass went back for the
marshmallows
yeah
I said bro let's [ __ ] get those
marshmallows like I'm hungry as [ __ ] so
we're going back to the kitchen me and
my homie angel
and um I see this fat kid eating my
marshmallows bro no Wow and his mom
they're right here they're right here so
I have that Nick sex dude I forgot all
about it you know I'm running boom we're
running from where we came and we see
this crowd so we're like all right but
like let's let's walk in this crowd
they're not gonna know I have this
purple shirt on there bro too
descriptive I didn't even think of it
boom We Walk In The Crowd right and I'm
all like just I didn't even look back
and I just hear like I don't even know
what they're cooking like Keys just
about game boom and he fat ass cop just
[ __ ] got both of us like that and he
put his knees on us and at the time like
I had like
you know what I'm saying I wasn't
feeling too good in my stomach so I kind
of sorry
it was bad bro sound like oh my God this
food here and I'm about to get arrested
go in jail sitting on a shark bro
and I have a Nick sacks too right that's
when I started remembering so I'm like
trying to get it out while I'm on the
floor and [ __ ] as he's tackling you you
shart yourself you're thinking about the
nickel sack he's trying to Cuff you this
is all everything going God
did he realize huh did he realize that
you [ __ ] [ __ ] your pants bro I didn't
say nothing cause like I didn't want to
like it was too soon you know what I'm
saying I just put your weight on the
kids
technically so
damn we haven't heard it God damn so he
found it oh see so he didn't find it yet
[ __ ] he puts me in the back apparently
they're saying someone broke a window
and a school so that's why they're like
really on my ass they thought we broke
into school but really there is the
hatch on the top that we went into okay
so they're lying they're like who the
[ __ ] broke a window we didn't break a
window also that lady in that kid did
look at he's got the marshmallows
you stole them look at him man that
little kid [ __ ] ate my marshmallow
bro to this day I wanted those there's a
big fluffy ones they were in like the
smallness the fact that the kid just
picked up a bag and started eating of
course score exactly that Mom is crazy
the mom too yeah that's [ __ ] up that's
insane to me so um
so they're alleging you broke a window
when you hadn't
yeah so that's what they made us look
bad and then I'm in the station now I'm
still having this in my thing that's all
I'm thinking about now now it's another
charge yeah so I'm I'm nah luckily it
wasn't oh okay but I I you know I have
like sorry on my pants like it was bad
for him on the way over there like boom
I they're like if you have anything now
say before we go to the main station and
then if it's there's a feeling so I said
I think I have something and he's like
you think you have something oh yeah
it's in my pants right
this this guy over there they just
walked out right now
that's another story but uh yes uh
long story short
I tell them yeah I have like some crumbs
it wasn't it was like a Nick but yeah
and he's searching myself he's like he
couldn't even find it but I know they'll
find it over there yeah so I'm like it's
right here in this pocket like you have
to open it and he finds it he causes
share and he says look what I found like
bro you didn't find it I told you about
it he said it was cool like he's all
happy right and then the sheriff comes
and that's when I tell you that's the
next time shut up pothead
um they made me feel bad
I was like 13.
I hope you know again then again I don't
understand them because I couldn't I
couldn't think like that you're a little
boy no that's I think it's crazy to me
that you're a kid and they're being so
crazy towards you about the unique
better they'd even catch you with
anything that was stolen but I feel like
you're getting profiled a lot at almost
every story is like damn do you just get
some like you know I'm cursed bro with
the gov with the law I don't know I was
just telling my homies that I'm like no
matter what I do no matter how clean I
drive no matter one time I was driving
so clean two times three times four
times
I'm talking about CBD in the packaging
bro
like not we
and they lock me up because it looks
like we
recently like this year like a few
months ago
another time I have a burnt joint this
small I told him CBD you can't test the
burns right it looks like weed or like
this Fam I'm sitting in jail paying
bonds gotta talk to lawyers over this
my next time um
I'm chilling I'm someone hits my bands I
just I bought a White Band they hit my
back bins
everything's cool right I have insurance
whatever
should I have a warrant oh I got court
to December at the time
or they gave me one in November
it made no sense like like it's like
something's just like preemptive [ __ ]
good in this situation I feel here so
another time
they arrest me again for Ticket ones
after that like this is all recent take
it orange brother
I get out again boom then this happened
in L.A um
what the hell this is all like in a
three-month ratio
that's sick friend damn no I feel you
then you're like I feel cursed I'm
cursed but then again then again 2023 is
a new year exactly you're about to put
your your effort and all your time into
something that everybody I mean they
give Awards on TV for music the [ __ ]
Grammys is broadcasting it's different
weed one day
might be more accepted but until you're
good in Texas I feel you so kind of like
you're on edge
all right I'm sorry that sucks I hated
it there for that reason I'm like I can
have [ __ ] Willie Nelson be your
poster boy and you're [ __ ] treat me
like a murderer over this [ __ ] flower
but meanwhile you're milking Willie
Nelson's image he's the face of Austin
Texas
you know what I mean like he's their
poster boy what the [ __ ] it's like
having Snoop Dogg be the face of [ __ ]
Dallas no okay yeah yeah I get what
you're saying sex is backward bro that's
okay that's where you're from it's kind
of hard to leave me from I get it I get
it
um
all right cool cool uh we have a segment
all right and basically I'm gonna ask
you a question you pick one or the other
that's it that's all it is yeah
um oh wait no this is a different
segment this is Marty's it's called
where you at so we ask you the same way
where you at with this like uh about yes
this or that Marty go for it okay all
right here we go
where you at with the five second rule
do you abide by it do you not think
about it if you drop something on the
floor or whatever it depends what fluid
is I think that's the only answer it
depends where I'm at if it's a street uh
no it's over October yeah hang on all
the dirt it's not that I always imagine
that the dirtiest [ __ ] ever
pissed right there last night
yeah you know everything that the worst
[ __ ] that could ever happen has happened
right there just happened to be where I
dropped my candy or something stupid
yeah many years a day yeah [ __ ] that
no this kind of just bleeds into the
second one too this is kind of like
germaphobe related where are you at with
like we call it raw dog and door handles
are you somebody that is doing the
sleeve over there after covid I turned
into that guy yeah or before because
it's kind of a personality type is what
these questions are getting I thought we
got me worse
oh we talk about it
we're all done the door handles oh
laughs
talking about when you go to the
restaurant like this you're getting down
no and opening the don't worry like that
or do you do I do this one sometimes oh
yeah go watch my [ __ ] hands see
that's what we do we do the sleeve damn
we said sleeve you thought we meant
banging I thought Dylan was getting down
I'm like I just used my sleeve
Texas what are you guys doing out there
no I thought you talking about I get
what you're saying now I just kind of
coin that term with the door handles I
should explain what the [ __ ] it means
first oh [ __ ] yeah okay go for it go for
it all right now where are you at with
knocking on wood being superstitious
count numbers in your head and [ __ ] like
that is that thank you
does me heavy I think you gotta knock on
wood sometimes just in case why not okay
all right because that's how I feel too
all right go for it
if you had to do one or the other solo
deep sea cave diving or jumping out of a
plane
oh I'm gonna jump on a plane yeah see
not one person says let's go deepsea
diving not one
special I mean all right you got that
but the [ __ ] I mean we go over this
every time jump out of the [ __ ] plan
is so horrifying but it's everybody's
answer yeah that's your point I'm
closing my eyes close my eyes just do
this I'm gonna open them at the end like
yeah that's [ __ ] awesome
yeah that's what I'll do uh I hated uh
haunted houses a kid my mom loves them
yeah bro how many times I've closed my
eyes
whoa whoa it just held on to someone's
hand ah and then one time I opened him
[ __ ] never again what a light bulb in
his mouth and it was just a head it was
obviously fake but that's the weird
thing about roller coasters you can
really close your eyes and almost not be
there oh I did on Jurassic Park the
other day when I took all right [ __ ] man
that drop I don't [ __ ] roller
coasters man I'd rather drive my car if
I go fast I couldn't see her going on a
roller coaster hell no you went on like
a real one no I went to the Jurassic
Park it dropped for eight seconds that's
all it is hell no
oh God all right here we go oh this is a
good one Marty
all right I mean if you have to pick one
for life as far as like uh vehicles for
your weed blunts papers bongs dabs pens
which one would you go with for life
I don't know they're just like
um
you say that one more time
blunts papers bongs dabs pens basically
any one item
I might have to go with papers same yeah
used to be bongs but then I was like
sometimes bongs hurt
he could just drain a lighter into a
bowl just oh I don't anymore cough
nothing his lungs are steel bro I don't
understand
yeah he's on help with now but damn I
mean I take rip for this Fool's
ridiculous go all right
oh there's a new [ __ ] in here you have
to pick
either one as far as like you have one
channel to subscribe to for life it
could be a music person or it can be a
YouTuber that you watch but you're just
subbed to that channel for life and
that's
Your Entertainment
music too yeah ah
you can pick one or the other okay
that's a good question
Michael Jackson right I didn't expect
that so yeah like Michael Jackson
the music it'll be a music party because
I love music I just try to jam music all
day oh how about this make it we should
do this what's your top three favorite
artists that you let's do doesn't have
to be just like the music that you make
doesn't have to be that genre what's the
top three we didn't do that we said the
playlist of Texas what's your playlist
like
what's your top three favorite music
artists it could be a band and anything
I don't think we asked that
um
excluding myself
um nah yeah cause I love driving myself
like but um
I'll say like
I [ __ ] do you baby right now who do you
baby uh that's never heard him it's
pretty hard you know I'm doing this
thing Texas
um
like an air like that no cap No Cap is
hard
um
two names I never heard of
and I just listened to a lot though but
like to my top three would probably be
right now I'm too
because they're on like a different way
that's what I like when people say she
had never heard it's like I'm gonna go
listen to that I want to hear it yeah uh
yeah it's pretty hard
all right and I guess just like my team
like easy 9-3
and the whole Camp you know what I'm
saying yeah
[Music]
uh I heard like uh one of your videos I
think you dropped like an awesome I
don't know if I can [ __ ] really
uh and [ __ ] in the background and like
in some of your Beats I heard a little
like East Coast influence where you
tapped into like that East Coast hip-hop
genre at all grown up oh
um
[ __ ] no not really I really grew up
listening like
like well maybe we want to stop music
was Lil Wayne it's a lot of our guests
first Yeah Lil Wayne well he was there
for everybody's for everybody he's been
here for [ __ ] 30 years it's true yeah
it's [ __ ] hard I was just saying the
other day like God there's this rapper I
don't really like but he popped up on my
playlist but then it had feature a
little win and went I'll listen to Lil
Wayne's on it so yeah I used a stretch
where he was probably the top featured
person for 2003 to five I feel you
where are you at with
paranormal activities or UFOs
out there in Texas oh yeah Texas must be
crazy out there I've seen two encounters
that I could say that was 100
like one encounty was with four friends
so it wasn't just like you wake up and
nobody knows they remember that [ __ ] I
know they remember that [ __ ] we're just
looking up at the stars like we're just
like bored as [ __ ] pulling the honor
back then pulling all night it was like
you're the coolest [ __ ] kid it's
always talking about pre-weed
before you guys start smoking weed yeah
oh pulled an all-nighter who can drink
sodas watch Cartoon Network yeah oh it's
seven in the morning everybody's hyped
yeah we're just looking at stars just
see this big starter they're like look
at that one so we're looking you just
see that [ __ ] star we're looking at
off like that
so I don't really take nothing of it you
know people they didn't believe it I
thought it was an alien but like a man
lived out of my life around like 15. I
just want to go see a Vega in the back
of my patio
green all the album everything I'm I'm
smoking right
for some reason bro some people told me
to look up
I don't know why let's [ __ ] look up
and I see like that bright light again
and it just moves right when I look up
and I was like oh [ __ ] sound same house
different [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah bro
creepier yeah oh he saw me see it
did you know I was like no
that's when I knew once I see it twice
it's twice as nice bro like you can't
just [ __ ] don't trip me out so bad
like it's [ __ ] with me they're like
you're smoking oh yeah you're high oh
pothead like [ __ ] I'm like no I
wasn't I wasn't tripping different I
seen that I don't know what the [ __ ]
I've seen I never had weird made me
hallucinations if you got that let me
get that right
Texas little kid yeah Garcia Vega like
thinking about I was getting high though
I'll get hot
um
but you said though you said the other
people witnessed it the same too yeah
see those people remember that time but
if they seen it the second time like me
they would really believe
I bet you they just like yeah yeah threw
it up taxes must be wild out here
there's so many sightings of wild [ __ ]
out here man it's getting crazy out here
but time gone over that time yeah
um so before we get out here dude we
want to ask a couple fan questions
because uh people are excited they hit
us up with one of the most highly
requested guests who's asking me dude
we're in the same like World of like
yeah we do we [ __ ] I know you do music
for sure that's a whole nother world
what I'm talking about
when it comes to weed it's like there's
only a handful of people that have been
doing it consistently for a long time so
when they come on the show people are
[ __ ] excited because they just wanted
it's your first interview it's the
community you know me like it's your
first like I want to hear what your
mind's got to say without well someone's
asking him [ __ ] not just
[ __ ] government man like smoking a
blunt
story times and all that [ __ ] everybody
I know that frame like my frame is right
here those four pictures you it's I just
know it's in the driver's seat camera in
the middle angle like that's your [ __ ]
so that's what I remember like
I think your name I think [ __ ] Story
Time videos if I can do a wild [ __ ] in
the car extendo [ __ ] blunts just
doing crazy [ __ ] so it's fun it's fun so
that's why we always do fan questions
when it's someone like this so for you
we got some fan questions I don't even
know how to say this motherfucker's name
W Murph
first car current car dream car
like what's your dream car what was your
first car you ever had because when
people look at you they think oh I'm 23
also he's only 23 and then they started
going okay because then they think I'm
working at McDonald's I'm like oh he
just said he works Dairy green I work at
Dairy Queen there's nothing wrong with
it but if you want to start doing
something else you got to go I'm gonna
risk and do this so maybe they you know
how many people like you said people got
more money than me and they're like
thank you for doing that video it helped
me out so these questions are like I
like to ask because you might be
inspiring little you you know I mean in
[ __ ] Nebraska or something important
the whole show that's the whole point so
what was your first car what's your
dream car okay so my first car was like
I was young you know I don't really have
like I don't have Mom and Dad that Watch
Me Whip I wish I did though but I don't
know so I was 15 I wasn't going to
school I worked hard to get this um 2002
Mercury Sable lb
that's what it's called emerald green
V8 too
hey for my first car I put up on the
Block I swear I thought it was a [ __ ]
right I put it and then uh all the
homies like damn that's Mike I really
don't know yeah and then he scored on
this huh you know I paid like 2500 real
quick easy money uh like cheap ass cars
I got a V8 though like yeah no it's fun
dude and it's always I can make it
better yeah
I back up first first day right I back
up in a car there's a car behind right
just back up until because I don't even
know how to drive I just bought a car oh
she got no license your kids
I just hit his car I'm like oh [ __ ] and
I get out and like he got scared because
all my homies were right there he just
went back
oh yeah
so yeah
that was my first car
um dream car right now money's not an
expense not I mean yeah people like a
Bugatti Hermes Bugatti like all right
bro five mil what's an attainable car
that you won't
just shoot yourself for buying you know
what I mean like if you spend five mil
in a car I get it if you're a
billionaire but it's like yeah five
million dollars that's another goal when
you're like crazy that's crazy [ __ ]
that's like my I bought two Yachts today
yeah I get the [ __ ] out of here man so
what's like a dream car like your
[ __ ] dream car
I want that Maybach SUV that shit's so
sick oh the little button that it
bounces
it's basically got a little Hydraulics
it just bounces oh [ __ ]
stock too yeah it comes with the car bro
I mean it has movement it looks it's not
getting off the wheels it's just doing
this the body
[Music]
a person close to our spot uh has that
one I saw it in person the other day
that two-tone is just
so [ __ ] badass man something about
the Maybach truck is just so bomb I
think I know what you talking about yeah
it's hard
oh I saw the version it's so sick so
that's a dream car yeah right now yeah
next year I plan together
hell yeah that's sick as [ __ ] yeah all
right that's a good see my first car was
a Dodge Intrepid it was a green one look
like a bird I saw so much weed in that
[ __ ] car though it paid for itself in
like a month
when I started using it damn yeah I had
I bought it at 14 and drove it back from
Portland Oregon with my sister oh she
was fit like bone on 16 and we just
boxed the car the whole Drive I got no
license no insurance but it made it back
man yeah that was my first car it was
green like how far is it by the way from
Oregon 11 hours door-to-door oh God damn
yeah when we drove off and went dad let
us go damn he's a [ __ ] impossible ass
that's all I can't think like God you're
a Batman dad you're letting us drive 11
hours with no licenses my whole family's
a truck driver so so I've been driving
since I was like [ __ ] five years old
by my like just driving the [ __ ]
diesel on the laps and taking the pickup
to the store I was like eight like this
is some [ __ ] I was in the country my
dad's not a responsible person but yeah
so I've been driving
um it's a [ __ ] dude the Maybach SUV is
so [ __ ] bomb sorry yeah keep thinking
about it all right so the next one next
question
uh from observed I don't know what do
you think of the tick tock what do you
think about Tick Tock in the music
industry what do you think is going to
look like next year because it it
actually can
it's kind of sometimes it's corny but
damn that [ __ ] really does it's like a
free marketing tool yeah of course that
just expands and it's just it keeps
going dude one little stupid [ __ ]
dance from one dude in a Kentucky can
make your song go viral it doesn't it's
crazy to me so that's that's the
question what do you think about that
whole wave right now and I think rappers
hop on it man because I I'm not really I
just make music I don't really like if
you try to do that that's cool and it
works it's cool but you can't really try
to hop on a wave you got to just do your
own thing as a rapper so you could get
known you can't be like oh it just
sounds like this you just hopping on
this way because like you were saying
earlier you gotta do it yourself
yeah so Tick Tock the other Tick Tock
music I think it's cool like if you're
in the club or like trying to have fun
you know yeah yeah that's cool all right
cool cool so all right next question
real quick johnnywood 13.
have you oh [ __ ] okay have you or any of
your homies started acting different
once you started becoming successful and
how do you move forward from the
situation that's a good question good
[ __ ] question Johnny how do you move
forward from the situation because I
know a lot of [ __ ] going
through that and it's it's not easy to
deal with
uh you just gotta like keep your
distance if you feel like somebody won't
even put any effort into you like you
doing to them just keep your distance
you know but like don't change who you
are you know I'm saying just
you can't just move with someone that's
that's not like you you know it's gonna
make you like do Spanish you know what
I'm saying
so yeah I always keep my distance
um
if those people want to be in my life
they'll show that effort to come and hit
me up you know what I'm saying yeah [ __ ]
like that yeah that's a good rules
follow it truly is man I heard wallow
say a check for who's checking for you
and I was like [ __ ]
God damn that is what it is let's go and
also
when people like influence call me three
months [ __ ] are busy bro you
also haven't called to him in three
months so you can't get mad at it yeah
cause I'm busy as [ __ ] too you know but
when I think it's something like hey bro
where are you how you been so it's not
always like
it's like who's putting effort into you
I guess I guess what you um is what I
mean like
who can add value to your life not like
yo you don't make me money for I'm not
chilling with you that's not what I mean
it's more of like dude do I have to just
go out of my way and I'm I'm not
elevating being around you because if
that's the case then you're stunting my
[ __ ] growth as a person not everybody
grows at the same time so yeah I think
you put it you put it perfect
um all right cool cool thank you for
that because I know a lot of
[ __ ]
wait
this next question is from x e y w k I
don't know your name it just says what
happened to that fool that's all that
smoked cat in it
you just laughs wait you made someone
can dude
it was a in a blunt I'm assuming yeah
did they know how long did it take to
notice it was pretty sad because
he's hitting the [ __ ] out of it right
bro bro this is
so he's hitting the [ __ ] out the blunt
we actually had to cut that real scene
out little no one knows this because he
was not knowing and he's like so I told
him and he's like bro that's [ __ ] up
let me smoke that long leg I was like by
the way are you right you right and he
didn't want to like be humiliated like
that by not knowing how bad is the weed
out there oh yeah yeah back then I'm
telling you like back then if he's like
yo this is a whole nother this is not a
plan yeah wrong substance hitting the
[ __ ] out the wood like I wrote it in the
wood
yeah that's embarrassing but damn bro
you don't know your terpenes at all huh
that's the cat piss
yeah I got that yeah somebody really
watches your [ __ ] heavy whatever
happened to that full of smoked Captain
I love that thank you for that one
um all right all right zero Blake
favorite video game do you do you play
video games
I used to and then you started editing
is that something nah I just okay I
didn't mind work hard yeah I stopped I
play against TV or nothing no more but
um
my favorite game is like
GTA of course solo like if I'm gonna go
online for a night that way I could play
with the gang or whoever wants to play
you know what I'm saying
yeah I stopped uh playing games started
editing
I'm like dude I gotta occupy because
what am I doing like those hours hours
could be pushed into something else and
then Marty took over fully like what two
years ago uh I'm just thinking about he
got my kids a PlayStation for Christmas
I got a four-year-old she got on
fortnite first time Victory she won bro
she's a little and legitimately [ __ ]
one
that Lobby sucks and they're all three
or your daughter's a profit she knew
what she was doing it wasn't she did she
had the headset and she was going I was
shocked when she showed you the dances
of like your kids Advanced huh
all right all right all right here we go
Narco 45 damn craziest trip on any drug
you've had
oh I think it'd be mushrooms
I freaking checked out how much things
not trips but like you become
spiritually wrong like
I
my first time eating mushrooms
um I ate them in a burger
oh [ __ ] no that's not a great idea
because that stunt made me not eat meat
for nine months oh it made me feel what
I ate like I was sick I got woke
and um
I just [ __ ] went through a spiritual
phase it was so crazy oh never heard
that before I [ __ ] with that dude it
didn't go away and it's still here you
know I'm woke you know like I know a lot
of knowledge I didn't know
but um
yeah it's sick what a trap yeah damn no
that's a that's a [ __ ] crazy trip to
have like oh you're vegetarian now no
you just ate something and now you're
talking I know you didn't expect oh [ __ ]
yeah
all right all right man that's scary
actually I wonder if it would have went
sideways if we just didn't do the burger
nah I still would have been like [ __ ]
up like you should have seen that I
uploaded the video but of course YouTube
they turn it down like it was all
mushrooms music video I took it like I
showed it with me taking it it was
awesome like my first stream trip I
jumped 100 bottles of water I thought of
bring more water bottles I'm just trying
to throw it up my homie said throw it up
and it don't feel better no you're
supposed to let what's that throw that
throat passes is when you start [ __ ]
P exactly
the first trip ever yes but so I'm
throwing up and it's intensifying and
I'm just getting more [ __ ] up every
time it won't go away so I'm like
peeking hard and I go to this restaurant
I'm just like cuddled up in the restroom
again next to the toilet shaking yeah my
boxes
he was tripping out hard dude it's crazy
damn yeah we did this all on video
it was even more crazy like because I
couldn't handle the video if I was
Dripping that hard exactly I wouldn't be
able to pay attention I feel yeah I told
my home I said record it for educational
purposes exactly for real if it's
educational don't do this and that
started plugging
us we accidentally [ __ ] tripped out
on the podcast not too much oh yeah we
ate some I ate too many mushrooms on
podcast like two months ago oh hell no
bro it's not fun [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm
trying to hold a conversation and there
was two guests so there's three people
next to me talking I'm just like and
then all these colors started breathing
and moving on me all these patterns
started moving oh I started conversating
with myself I hate that [ __ ] never again
bro all right last question last
question here we go
e-f-a-b-u asked him to tell a story by
the time he thought he got away from his
PO officer and had a blunt in his ear
yeah yeah that [ __ ] was crazy I had this
officer named Rachel I could talk about
her now because I'm not a kid she is
[ __ ] she's pretty cool but not really
you know what I'm saying so I came out
dirty every time I just like took
advantage like I was like should not get
like me you know what I'm saying
but on 420 bro 420
I waited to 10 because she usually comes
like at 10. but I don't know why I
didn't wait like a little bit longer I
just thought like at 10 o'clock I'm
gonna go smoke now I've been waiting all
[ __ ] day for her to pull up because I
know she can pull up on 10 at night yeah
and she's doing a house check pull it on
my house bro I'm a kid she's gonna knock
on the window and she'll wake me up and
[ __ ] so I I I'm over here two blunts
Road on my ears
I'm going to my Mercury say well it'll
be you know the first car
and uh
I'm in the car and I'm waiting for my
girl at the time to come to the car so
I'm in I'm in the driveway still thank
God because if I was gone I would have
got the horn
I look behind me and I see a [ __ ] the
PO the probation
and I'm like oh [ __ ] I have the punch on
my ears so I take the blunts out and I I
don't even remember what I did with him
I just dropped him like that
and then I seen them they went with the
lights to my house so I got out the car
[Music]
I see them come around and they're with
my girl
so like it's all three of them coming
and then
they're like why are you out here
because I had zero tolerance I had to be
inside like actually outside yeah after
six I can't go outside
so I'm like she's like why are you out
here
and I was like I'm just taking out the
trash like I'm a girlfriend
I'm just taking out the trash and she's
like oh well
I low key
I don't know like I did smoke but like
I I like trade and took a shower you
know what I'm saying so I still laying
there pointing the flashlight to my eyes
and I'm lit as hell
and she's all like
what are you doing yeah Etc like she
knew I was high she smiled and guess
what she tells me you know you have a
drug test tomorrow right and I'm like
yeah I know she's like okay you better
come out clean and then she dipped off
that's it yeah did you test you oh yeah
and then she liked me up oh she was
seriously [ __ ] like me oh it's 4 20.
she decides to get you no she didn't
lock me up then no I'm saying that she's
like she knew you were getting [ __ ]
hot she let me smoke because she knew
exactly what was gonna go down that
night or what went down already and she
said and guess what I didn't show up the
next day no pretended I was sick and
then the next day she came to the crib
and then she [ __ ] it
she came with like a big old dude and
then at the door she's like you ready to
take that drug test I was like yeah but
I wasn't because like they opened the
restroom door and just like this big old
dude adding her they're just looking at
me yeah but you're underage yeah that's
illegal and I'm like I'm like like
there's a mirror right here big ass
mirror too like if they're not even
looking they're looking at the mirror
like it's weird so I couldn't pee like
you know when someone's looking at you
and you just can't pee so I mean I've
never had nobody to stare at me pissing
but I can imagine it it was like that it
was like I'm trying to go but like it's
just not normal so I'm like I can't go
right now but and boom as soon as I say
that that big dude he put his hand cuts
on you and then he takes me and that's
when I did like six to nine months just
[ __ ] coming out dirty just that's it
oh Texas get it together
one day we're gonna be looking back on
this and going damn they used to arrest
people for weed yeah one day
well damn dude
that was the end of the fan questions
and I didn't want to like ask you 500
things there's so many things I want to
ask you but also like come back someday
like when you're coming back you know
what I mean like we're coming here in
season three this is one of the last
episodes of our season it's about the
episode [ __ ] 100. let's go man
that's so [ __ ] awesome Marty
um before we get out of here though how
can everybody find you YouTube Twitter
do you Twitter I don't please man
anybody that makes music get on Twitter
yeah just [ __ ] use Twitter it's the
best thing you're gonna have you're
never gonna get deleted you can always
promote yourself people [ __ ] people [ __ ]
with Twitter just yeah it's one thing I
suggest to everybody just get on Twitter
because
you can actually go like yo I'm an
actual artist I'm using Twitter give me
the [ __ ] check mark give me my [ __ ]
give me Twitter [ __ ] with people when
they're actually doing things yeah you
know what I'm saying is I suggest you
get on Twitter but Instagram you still
gotta choose your same one yeah young
Mike 210 210 yeah young Mike 2-0 do you
still [ __ ] with Snapchat or no no
Snapchat deleted you oh yeah yeah me too
some [ __ ] bro
um so no Tick Tock either right not yet
but if you do so right now as of now the
shit's fake
you see a young mic when it's fake all
right he doesn't have one right now so
just go to his Instagram and show your
habit and then YouTube Just young Mike
yeah this young Mike
yeah music Young Mike all that on
everything Spotify Apple everything yeah
I'm like that's the brand
good [ __ ] let's go but preferably
Spotify yeah preferably Spotify shot
Spotify for [ __ ] teaming up with this
[ __ ] yeah
um Mario got anything else this was
great man thank you for coming yeah dude
this is my phone how long did we go man
when I found out this was gonna happen
hour 50. damn yeah
so [ __ ] happy yeah Marty's because we
were talking about it a couple of months
ago but then you got trouble because
you're supposed to come on the show and
I went he hasn't posted in like two
weeks oh he's in trouble oh you see what
happened was I I finally got my cases
they were talking about it like we're
gonna drop like because I have I'm
investing in a lawyer so that was when I
was supposed to come
I ended up doing a month in jail I knew
it because you didn't post for like two
weeks I'm like they wanted to do that
month but it dropped my big charges and
I dealt with everything now I'm doing
five more charges that's the thing I
just I just knocked out five times
but eventually you get overdue by the
time 2024 comes and you're like yo
remember I was in trouble all the time
no I'm not yeah so next time you're on
here hopefully you're like no I'm
[ __ ] chilling you should try to make
it on New Year's Eve again yeah next
year come through like no how much it's
gone and did you see my music video
online again I mean like that's the the
goals music so 2023 uh young mic music
is what you're going into harder oh yeah
weeds there weed's there but we can
always be like your homie you chill with
sometimes weed videos like yeah I love
doing them
yeah it doesn't have to be the star of
the show yeah that's a good way to put
it all right cool thank you for being
here man please uh yeah be safe while
you're still out here I don't know when
you're going home but we need to
probably chill two more days I'm
hello key and hold on it's as this is
premiering Monday Night Football you got
Bengals or bills oh you know I don't
even watch football
but if you grew up in Texas real quick
you have to be in Dallas town right yeah
okay Texas are too [ __ ] new for
everybody
yeah okay Texas Mexican shit's different
Justin cobwes it's different out there
like the cowboy love and getting [ __ ]
faced is I mean real the Raider love and
watching them lose out here is the same
thing because we all know the Raiders
are not gonna like do we uh one day one
day they'll do good but yeah it's just a
different vibe I got a couple homies
from Texas I'll be out there uh January
22nd January 20th I'll see you in
Houston in Dallas guys oh yeah
um Ted Talk January 6th January 6.
appreciate you guys Friday anything else
you want to add anything else like new
projects or anything that you want to
sell the fans before we get out of here
no album coming soon you know be ready
for the music
thanks for having me appreciate you man
it's been a minute so I'm excited oh
yeah all right thank you so much for
Marty Mike thank you so much guys this
has been the dope's usual podcast we are
here to talk about live drugs problems
accomplishments everything in between
have a dope ass day
good [ __ ] man
what's up guys this is not an Android we
just want to announce the giveaway
winners last week in the Christmas story
time last week's episode we gave away
four different giveaways from all the
companies that we have so these are the
winners being announced right now this
is how we did it we said go to our
Instagram which is right here dope usual
podcast say go to our Instagram tag a
friend that's literally it that's all
you had to do we just want to say thank
you so I just went through and picked
four random people so first up the
person that's gonna win the dope as
usual package the one that gets
everything that we have all the Merch
this person's name on Instagram is
Gilbert grap3 oh Gilbert Grape with a
three all right Gilbert Grape Gilbert
shots you you win uh please DM us we're
gonna post this on Instagram also please
DM us on Instagram and we'll get
everything out to you second giveaway
winner guys this was for the push trees
gift card it's 250 to our website
whatever you want we'll ship it right
out to you the winner is big
lp420 thank you very much dude we're
gonna get to push trees package out to
you let us know what you want DM us with
all your information have a dope ass day
number number three this is for The
Re-Up The Re-Up is our company uh we
just started with our friends this is an
online head shop online smoke shop we're
a brand new company all right we're
brand new company so we can't be just
throwing out we got profit margins we
have partners and stuff all right so
we're giving away 150 for free gift card
150 bucks whatever you want shipped to
your door this is somebody I picked
because I recognize the profile picture
I see I have a photograph from memory I
see you guys all the time this person is
in almost every comment section this is
right here the name is Nick Storm review
I see you all the time dude thank you
for always supporting us I see you
always messing with the wrestlers and
stuff that's awesome you're gonna get
150 to the rehab shop please make sure
you DM us and that's going to be on this
Instagram remember dope as usual podcast
shoot us a DM the fourth and final
winner this is for the dopest shop this
is either 500 shopping spree to the dopa
shop or if you're under 21 or maybe
you're out of the country because we
can't ship stuff to you you're gonna get
a 500 gift card so spend it on whatever
you want or if not it's for the doping
shop and before I announced the last
winner thank you guys this is just to
say thank you we appreciate you so much
thank you we have almost 5 000 people
enter the giveaway we appreciate you the
last winner thank you guys so much for
participating the last winner is Witchy
dot Jess witchy dot just shoot us a DM
thank you so much we just want to say
thank you so much for entering the
giveaway have a dope ass day
[Music]